Michael Knowles from The Daily wire it
is one of the greatest websites alive
you know this guy is smart because he's
friends with Ben Shapiro another
SuperDuper smart guy host of the Michael
Noel's show Michael great to have you on
here big fan how are you tonight doing
very well thank you for having me all
right we're gonna go through some of the
lowlights this week in the media our
media culture first off ABC threw
together a special promo for their
reporters elevating their reporters in
the wake of the George Floyd story let's
take a look I actually haven't seen this
before
go combined we have nearly 400 years of
experience covering the news but long
before that we've been black in America
I'm telling a story and I am seeing an
image of me a black man being killed
okay
featuring their black correspondents I
don't have a problem with it necessarily
let me think about it for a moment
Michael what do you think well I've got
some news that I can break for them
which is that the image that they were
seeing was actually not the reporter it
was another man a different person named
George Floyd it wasn't the reporter
there are different people at this is
more and more evidence that the riots
that we're seeing across the country now
I suppose across the world are not about
the sad death of this man George Floyd
they're not about any of the things that
black lives matter and associated
movements tell us they're about it's
about a radical left-wing agenda and the
way that activists and I include
journalists among activists are
fulfilling this is by making it about
themselves so you saw this yesterday on
Instagram if you happen to go on
Instagram everyone was posting little
black squares apparently if you post a
little black square you've solved racism
once and for all and we have justice but
of course that sort of slacktivism does
nothing other than signal one's own
virtue other than signal that you are
one of the good guys you're part of the
liberal team it's become all about
oneself and one's own reputation and
sadly any type of justice has been lost
in the mix so I I hate that stuff on
social media I think it's so cheap I
really do
and look I bashed the the fake news
all the time I will say this though that
might have come from the promotion's
Department you know what I mean the
promotion's Department put it together
like I did see two guys in there that I
like TJ Holmes who I've never met Byron
Pitts who I have once or twice I think
those guys are pretty good reporters
pretty straight but the whole thing
might have been a little bit cheesy hey
listen I want to step forward to this
The Wall Street Journal I want to put
this headline up I'm not sure if you saw
this but we'll go through it together
Wall Street Journal had a story the myth
of systemic police racism and it was a
very interesting story it was done by
Heather McDonald of the Manhattan
Institute and she went through it that
the data suggests that the danger is not
coming from police regarding the death
of black men it's coming from other
forgive me black men and this that the
police are responsible for this moment
it's been overstated they may have been
responsible for the death of George
Floyd but this is an uncomfortable truth
that too many in the media don't like to
talk about and they don't like to talk
about honestly it's too easy to paint
that law enforcement you know in this
bad light you have any thoughts on that
of course I thought it was an excellent
piece by Heather McDonald if you saw the
riots if you saw the media coverage of
the riots which they are referring to as
peaceful protests you would think that
we have this massive epidemic in this
country of unarmed black men innocent
Lachman being killed by racist cops
every year you would think how many
would be killed me I don't know 9,000 no
900 no 90 no the actual answer is nine
nine unarmed black men were killed last
year by police one of whom had a loaded
gun in his car during a chase every
death is a tragedy but of course that is
not evidence of systemic slaughter and
it reminds us of an important point here
which is that this entire movement the
so-called black lives matter movement
which doesn't care very much about black
lives as it burns down largely black
neighborhoods is founded on a lie was
founded on this lie of systemic massive
police brutality it was founded on the
lie that Michael Brown was was killed he
was executed in Ferguson Missouri with
his hands up saying don't shoot
that was disproven by multiple autopsies
by the grand jury by black eyewitnesses
it's a lion so I think some people want
to go a little soft and say well maybe
maybe they have a point but I don't
think so and I think those lies are
causing real harm to a lot of people
ironically especially black Americans
and there's this they're very selective
about the information they report
George Floyd is now a Civil Rights icon
posthumously and what happened to him
was an atrocity it was one of the
ugliest things I've ever witnessed now
it does turn out that he had a criminal
record from ten years ago I don't think
not in a million years a million light
years does that mean he deserved what
happened to him he did not it should not
have happened to him hardcore criminals
I don't care they should never be
apprehended like that he wasn't a
hardcore criminal this was all in his
past but I think in their effort to be
politically correct not to be ever
accused of being insensitive or even
worse there are certain things that they
refuse to touch and I think it's it's
it's troubling and because sooner or
later people are going to hear about
this at the trial or something and I I
don't know why certain things are
stifled it like like we can't handle it
I can still think that this guy it
shouldn't have happened to him he seemed
like a nice guy yet
why would the mainstream media go there
of course and this has unintended
negative consequences when the media
cover things up or when the media lie of
course nobody thinks that because this
this guy George Floyd had a criminal
past he should have been killed in this
altercation but the media have lost
their credibility here